it's like a disaster the city is almost
ruined in the district where i'm living
it's
like no houses which were not bombed
there's about eight houses here that
have been flattened utterly flattened
there were about six people from one
family
who died here
look at what these bombs have done and
they they the people who were around the
village spoke of hearing three
really loud explosions as as bonds were
dropped
[Music]
[Music]
we are bombed
every day every night and non-stop here
are people
who are who live together
and we we manage
this is
you know it is good that we have a high
silly high ceiling you know but because
in most places it is not
possible to you know to sleep even
horizontally
[Music]
don't trust putin putin never keep their
promises about humanitarian corridor
during the eight years of war and i'm
not very much optimistic frankly
speaking
[Music]
for democracy
because
democracy is precious and one man
couldn't decide that another country
shouldn't have it
[Music]
[Applause]
enjoy peace it's really valuable don't
take for granted what you have now
because
it's so vulnerable
so enjoy life enjoy please